hello I'm a citizen and I'm the  government we've put a special tax on  tobacco products to discourage smoking  oh okay  because it's expensive to take care of  smokers so your disincentivizing us from  smoking right also we put a special tax  on drinking alcohol because that's a  problem all right  also we're taxing your income okay  hello I'm a citizen and I'm the  government I bet you can't stop being a  hypocrite for one minute you know I've  taken that bet but gambling is illegal  [Music]  hello I'm a citizen and I'm the  government I just got paid today and you  took a lot of my money about that I will  slowly start giving you some of that  money back if and when you reach age 67  what happens if I don't make it to age  67  [Music]